why do you feel that now is the right
time in your career to take this leap of
faith and join the celebrity big brother
world
uh i think it's it's a good idea for me
right now because um i'm about to do a
really big show
um
that i'm involved with
pretty big person and
i just think that now is the time to get
out there and do this before i
reach
resign to only in back of the camera
that's that's my plans
and as a celebrity you're accustomed to
people watching your move and living
under a microscope but are you ready for
the public to see you in a different
light watching you 24 7.
i think the public knows me
they know exactly who i am
so i don't think i have any fear with
that
what part of yourself are you most
scared or embarrassed for the public to
see example
are you like grumpy in the morning are
you super addicted to coffee
say that am i what is there is there
anything you're like kind of embarrassed
or you don't want the public to see so
for women it may be like no makeup or
are you super grumpy in the mornings are
you addicted to coffee i'm addicted to
coffee that's for sure
that definitely but i think most
americans are so
and is there anyone you do not want to
see walk through the doors of the
celebrity big brother house
no
there is it